hello everybody my name is markiplier
and you guys have asked me to check out
the second game mode that was unlocked
when I beat slender the 9 pages so here
we go slender killer mode
okay yeah what were you expecting I'm
killing slender what you saw a slender
killer man Oh No haha you're so silly
look Kirsten how are you talking about
don't be so crazy
I have to admit I tried this out
beforehand and I was just to see what it
was to see if I could make a video out
of it and it turned out to be probably
the most awesome thing I've ever seen in
my entire life
ah I just missed the triple shot you
guys would've liked to see the triple
shot it's hard to spam the space button
like this yeah you can't see but my head
is hiding the score my score is
astronomical at the moment
oh look it's a big Slendy I've also got
ammo I don't know what it does though I
wasn't able to try that out I didn't get
very far
oh god my hair my wrist guy hurts so
much
yeah ah piss I've got lots of lives
anyway I seriously have whoa bullet time
mode I just need to get that triple shot
I like that triple shot
ha ha
you guys aren't hearing it as loud as I
am cuz I'll turn down the video audio
for you guys quit man is this getting
crazy it was like the most ridiculous
thing I've ever seen
I got hit targets one day
what's the mo do how do I release the
ammo I know it's like the big bomb but I
can't seem to get it to go
ah you keep making me messed up there we
go
I brought up talking about
I don't know how far this goes but I'm
on level 18
ah got it
so 21 war hahaha what the damn it huh
pass up fear I don't have that many
lives stop it stop it stop it stop it
grrrrrr douche go away go away
ah really I live now you gotta get me oh
no oh come on I such ball
oh okay alright I guess that's it then
so hey Sonny how you doing there that's
got a little buddy so no just a quick
look at this little game mode if you
want try for yourself you got a beat
slender the 9 pages so get it get over
your little fear of Slendy he's not that
scary and then you can blow them up and
try to beat my high score
4750 oh yeah so let me know what you
think and thank you everybody so much
for watching click the in Facebook more
videos in I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
Hey
Oh
bud
ah
ah I'm in a